Well, to get some
inspiration about this,
let's talk about what humans do, and
visual object categories in humans.
And there was work in
what is referred to as
Basic Level Categories
in human categorization.
It was st started by Eleanor Rosch,
series of seminal
papers back in the 70s.
Continued on by Lakoff and
other cognitive scientists.
And what they found is,
there are certain levels of description
that seem to have a preferred
place in human cognition.
So for example, the basic level was
the highest level in the category,
which you could say that objects have
the same, or similar, perceived shape.
So if I ask you to think of the shape
of a German Shepherd you can, but
if i ask you to think of the shape of
a dog, you probably can do that too.
If I ask you to think of
the shape of a mammal,
what you're going to do is you're
going to think of the shape of a couple
of representative types of mammals.
You don't actually have a shape for
mammal.
Typically also,
you can make a mental image.
If I say, you know,
make a mental image of a dog,
you'll probably come up with something.
If I say make a mental image
of an animal, you're going to
pick some animal and then if I were to
ask you what it was you wouldn't tell me
it's an animal you would tell me it
was a deer or something like that.
By the way you can do
reaction time experiments,
where, let's suppose you want to ask
people to push a button yes or no.
I'm going to show them a picture and
one task is you're supposed
to say is it an animal?
Another task you're supposed
to say whether it's a dog.
It turns out you're faster at knowing
that it's a dog than you are at knowing
it's an animal.
And that's a very robust finding and
you, you can, you can do that.
And then there's this thing that
typically this is the level that
children understand earlier.
So they'll learn about dogs before
they'll learn about animals,
they'll learn these words.
And there's one written here about
having motor actions interact.
You can imagine there's a set of things
you do with dogs that sort of span
dogs, right?
Right?
It's probably not the same set of things
you do with animals.
Right?
You probably pet dogs.
You probably want to pet most dogs.
Probably pet all dogs generically
if you're a dog person.
The idea is that you have these,
these interactions.
So there's this preferred
level within the human.
And you might wonder why I'm spending so
much time talking to you about this.
Well if you go to the MIT libraries and
you type in,
you could actually find this called NOC,
natural object categorization,
which by the way,
was my PhD thesis back in 1987.
Please don't go and read it,
it's not so great, but
I was worried about this notion
of perceptual, organization and
how you would organize your categories
to make them good for perception.
The one thing I lucked out on is
that by the time I did my thesis,
the AI tech reports were up to 1001, so
I got tech support 1001 as the number,
and and that's great because it sounded
like it was an important one or first.